how people have been infringed on
copyright it has progressed over time
and how conversely the means of fighting
them is measured in means of
infringement has also progressed over
time okay so that's that nice and simple
let's have a look at southern ones we've
already mentioned right how do people
infringe on copyright in the past like
in there in the era of like you know
cassette tape and that kind of thing
what was the what is the method okay
physical copies so suppose what that
means is you know you buy it you buy the
actual thing and then you have the means
to physically reproduce it okay
sometimes that's easy and sometimes it's
harder okay I remember when CD burners
started actually becoming affordable
right an error on started panicking
because if people could get not just a
arm you know a physical copy that was
like the original but a physical copy
that was exactly identical right I would
make software piracy you know music
piracy all take off okay so make your
physical what are the measures do that
people use to infringe on copyright yeah
I couldn't have said it better myself
okay now let's try and get this so what
we say geographical relocation we mean
things like say moving moving to another
country right now why would
so such as our best rate okay and Lizzie
on isn't the only one now hold on let's
just pedal back for a second how is this
relevant at all Howl's Moving countries
connected to means of infringement in
any way why would really to another
country and it could be you know or
could be say Switzerland or Norway why
would that make any difference Adam yeah
good so because copyright laws vary
wildly from country to country okay you
know a lot of I Conrad laws were looking
at just hit the video just now we're
specific to the u.s. right now it's very
important that you understand because
there are these differences in law right
moving to other countries is a way for
people to get away from that okay so
notable examples are people who have
exploited this are things like
megaupload that's been the most recent
one okay things like say websites like
say the pirate bay okay which by the way
are leads to another one of the separate
means infringement just before we get
out of that you see these the owners of
these kinds of our websites have gone to
countries where the laws of being just
not as restrictive matson a loser so the
government's where they live aren't
going to put earth not persecute
prosecute them for the kinds activities
they're doing right and it's been
notorious how difficult it's been not
impossible but difficult for other
countries to try and get ahold of these
people and you know actually get them
from other countries for prosecution
what's that call by the way when you
definitely extradition right so the US
for instance was trying to extradite the
the people who run and organize these
kinds of science all right now I said
you know the pyre bait is notable for
one of the kinds of beads infringement
what's it called okay so
so downloading I suppose we can put this
under the broad heading off on light
distribution right online now by the way
as we go through online distribution
when you say downloading that seems that
a virtual particular image daily there's
a server okay and it's got whatever
content is copyrighted and you put it
there and then other people come to it
download why buy it you know for the
people who are infringing copyright
right why might that be a problem why
might that be a dangerous way to
infringe copyright yeah yeah good so if
you're putting content out on a server
okay number one it's out there in the
public as opposed to you know for
instance if i was making physical copies
okay i could have like some you know
some shady alley you know and say hey
I've got some going to do content here
but it's relatively unknown when you're
out there on the internet right it's
notoriously open-air in public not only
that right if you own a server or if
you're hiring the server from somebody
um you cannot do that anonymously you
cannot do it anonymously and you can try
you can set up you know proxies you can
have other people with fake names like
kind of thing but essentially if you
earn a server that people can download
from your name your identity are
attached to that server okay so if I
find oh you know people are hosting my
copyrighted material on such-and-such
server there are means for me to go to
law enforcement agencies and say hey who
owns this who's responsible for this and
they can be tracked down now therefore
this is one reason why the Pirate Bay
has been so successful you don't just
have to have a server where you can
download this on if you want to do
online distribution what's another
popular way of doing it so yeah okay so
this is worth discussing okay Peter p or
PM to PR right it's a different model
instead of a server one central location
that all but all these different people
are guru or rather i get for
on the copyrighted data okay what's
peer-to-peer it's a look at these guys
out here okay and as they download the
content they each have a copy of it
right so these different our peers can
be leveraged for further distribution
cc's insanely clever right so what's
happening is you've got all these
clients and assuming you know same one
or two of them get a copy of the
copyrighted data okay these can then be
employed to pass it to other people who
can then pass it to other people right
does this make sense okay so
peer-to-peer so the first the most
famous instances of this what are some
names resolute a live wire okay a big
one course in use a while ago start at
the end and four in four starts torrents
right okay it's a whole software
architecture built out of being able to
pass things between people you can see
how this is so much more difficult to
track down it's not impossible really ok
ok now I'm sort of running out of space
we've got a lot of the beheadings we're
missing kind of a really simple one
right who's been to it's not name any
names a Southeast Asian country shall we
say right and it's like oh look there's
all these movies you can get on DVD
we're horrid a second this movie hasn't
even come out in Australia or it's still
in the cinema what's happening it's not
physical copies of some DVD that
someone's bought what they done what are
they then they've gone in to the cinema
right and they've actually literally
feels right how
[ __ ] it have you never cease enjoying a
movie and then suddenly you know weird
with some titles appear like how do I
turn this off is we're setting for tell
you know it's just there or are you're
watching it and is it suddenly you hear
you hear the sound of laughter or like
someone getting over cerrar I didn't go
to the bathroom right where'd this come
from that's right ok so no it's not to
be underestimated because it's um it's a
massive industry ok it's a massive
massive industry and you can see why why
is it hard to fight this particular
means of a piracy of infringing
copyright how how was it difficult
anyone in their phone can do it now ok
so when we talked about physical copies
and said you know sometimes it's hard to
get a hold of the equipment required for
this literally everyone's got the
equipment required for this in their
pocket right ok so let's think about
what are some of the ways that are
companies or organizations have started
to fight all of these methods ok for
some of it let's try and be specific
right for something like geographical
relocation we already mentioned what's
the method the government's I'm trying
extradition right so try and get the
event leaving the country try and get
them back in the country and then
prosecute them ok for Britain these laws
what other kinds of carbonaceous did you
come up with any any of these different
yeah
okay good serial codes are Porky's rate
is often what they're called okay so the
whole idea is that you know if i buy
some software you don't just need the CD
which has a sovereign oh you need a
specific set of numbers and letters that
will allow you to activate this is we
often call this product activation right
that will allow you to activate the
software and actually have it usable or
more usable for more than 30 days some
kind of period looks there for grace you
know I lost my thoughts my key now by
the way having mentioned this doesn't
this mention another way of infringement
people have seen this is a
countermeasure and they've designed a
counter counter measure deliberately
designed to go after this what is it
okay now so you need in context of
battle okay so let's figure out this
fact how does how does a number work as
a key right and especially because you
can't just have specific ones because
you know millions of people might buy
this piece of software right so these
codes are these Keys will fit
mathematical rules right often call me
and that algorithm is stored within the
piece of software so it can tell whether
you put in a dodgy code or one that's
actually legit right now if people can
work out what that algorithm ears they
can make their own codes or kids that
would fit it to it okay and these are
called I'm putting these are called key
generators so you can see this sort of a
on the sort of a technology arms race
that's happening between these two
opposing sides okay all right what other
can measures are they against copyright
open
let's keep on going after this idea of
product application or activation so
often now because say maybe 15 years ago
you can internet right in it access to
it there's not something that just
everyone have okay a lot of people have
it but not everyone these days that's
not the case like you companies can
assume software companies can assume
everyone has the internet so they can
make this product activation method not
just a code right but an online
activation so you've got to get on to
some website and say I'm just bought
this piece of software and this is robot
from or whatever and then then provide
you with the key and then they log the
fact that you've activate this piece of
software they see why this is a step up
on this right because if you've got a
serial code right old are less
sophisticated methods are piece of
software that employ this would allow
several different computers to work on
the same serial right because each one
is just checking does the number work on
the algorithm but you can use the number
multiple times you see how online
activation sort of overcomes that
problem because I might use the code
once and then you come along with my
copy use the same code but since it's
got online the company has a record of
the fact that a key has been used
already it's been taken okay and so it
has to be deactivated by me the original
before it can actually be reused okay in
order to add any more countermeasures
also there any other suggestions
yeah something Cody okay so encoding
right how does this work this is a
little bit like water marks right you
know how on a on a note right currency
we have all of these little things that
all looks and crannies little details
that have been hidden inside the note so
we can tell the genuine thing from a
fake right now this is tricky because
you know it's all prostituting zeros and
ones but there are ways to encode you
know say a watermark type ID are kind of
software right which validates something
as genuine okay so it's similar to this
idea of activations validation now let
me show you one more way it's very very
sophisticated of trying to fight
infringement that gets after this one is
downloading an online distribution 1 i'm
going to show it to you you see if you
can explain it to me ha okay now um you
guys know I have been uploading videos
and I noticed something interesting when
i was uploading some of the videos that
are were taken a while ago difference
you may remember is it last year or the
year before i think it was last year one
of the videos one of the things that i
did was i sang a song my side yen per
meters check signing in these silences
Oh
ok
i'ma show you is sort of like a arm a
back end view of all the videos that
I've got and you'll notice I'm going to
ask you to look for something unusual
okay you see there's this green symbol
not sure if you can make it out to green
simple green rectangle with a dollar
sign on papa what does it indicate
indicates adverse events being applied
to any of these videos right so YouTube
closet monetization right you've got a
video you want to monetize it so you can
earn revenue offer okay and you'll
notice that there are a couple of videos
down here which don't have it right now
what's going on if you have a look at
you have a look at the settings yep this
is a video that I did not take by I
wasn't even glance to apply the person
who did take it um but I can't put ads
on now that's how okay why
I blamed in civics Laura okay cataract
the transfer here um what is this video
off what was actually doing I was senior
song okay my guitar I bus there it is
you can watch it office now what's
happening i was performing actually i
was performing to salt or parts of two
songs that are actually recognized by
youtube okay now what's goin on here uh
my voice my guitar and yet an algorithm
has been employed by Google for owns
YouTube that can actually sense that
these songs have copyright applied to
them right namely good riddance my green
day at hand and friday by rebecca black
so it doesn't permit me to serve ads why
why because i'm not permitted to use
this copyrighted material for that
purpose are or for commercial purposes
to earn money on trip okay now if i go
back you can see the other videos the
worrier which has the same problem is
this one is a 20 minute video of me um
getting away all my hair cut off because
those raising funds now wow I wasn't
seat trust me I wasn't seen you okay why
would this video have problems with it
why would Google raise a red flag yeah
this is just happening in the quad and
the préfet just happened to be pumping
out a playlist in the background of you
know popular music that kind of thing
now Google picks it up it's not even the
main thing you can even talking you can
hear you know the buzz of the the hair
cutting shears whatever they call it's
all the way in the background but do the
computer audio and it senses it okay so
yeah essentially if we don't work out
it's just I that would be one way to do
it now that's not the only thing right
so what are we calling this right and
this is a detection algorithm that's not
the only thing that YouTube might choose
to do with your video in my case they
just disable ads right however what they
might do instead is they might disable
your on your video right or they might
pull your video down all together okay
so did you get depends right it's not
just a a blanket response i use this
algorithm to take
different kinds of measures based on
what they see in the video okay so there
you go there's a whole series of
infringement sways to oppose and breach
copyright and you can see our all these
different measures of fighting and these
are going to progress and continue
expanding I expect as on technology
advances